féroce d'avocats et colombo de porc un
menu exotique pour ces élèves du collège
de la mondre pour la semaine du goût
l'établissement a choisi la thématique
des îles d'une éducation culturelle qui
passe aussi par la cuisine c'est superbe
a permis de découvrir d'autres saveurs
et j'ai pas trop l'habitude de manger ça
j'aime tout ce qui est peas et 700 plat
que je connais et que j'apprécie
naturellement le département est
responsable de la restauration scolaire
notamment dans les collèges depuis 2009
celui des yvelines participent à cet
événement national jusqu'au 16 octobre
plusieurs animations sont proposées pour
sensibiliser les jeunes est important
pour les enfants
d'avoir cette éducation bout cette
éducation aux produits
cette éducation comment est ce qu'on
fait on fait pour produire sont
justement tous les produits qui arrivent
dans les assiettes donc l'éducation à la
consommation notamment pour cette 27e
édition la marraine n'est autre que
babette de rozières c'est elle qui a
confectionné le menu du jour je crois
que les enfants un certain engouement
pour ce genre de cuisine puisque c'est
pas une cuisine qu'ils mangent tous les
jours et cela permet aussi de voyager un
petit peu dans nos assiettes et d'un
curieux les enfants ont goûté ils ont
aimé ça fait le palais y songeait lille
fera faire le palais leur goût et nous
sommes là pour ça d'ailleurs éduquer au
goût c'est aussi éduquer à des
comportements alimentaires à partir de
cette thématique culinaire on associe
les professeurs dans la pédagogie que
eux aussi puiss du coup créer du lien
autour de ces opérations cette semaine
les élèves goûteront aussi à l'île de ré
et à la corse en 2010 la gastronomie
française a été inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco son chiffre
d'affaires s'élève à 60 milliards
d'euros par an